c'est du journal sylvie vartan
cette fois elle ne chante pas elle ne
danse pas elle ne joue pas dans un film
non plus elle prête son corps son corps
comme modèle de beauté et sa fille et sa
plume bien sûr dans un livre de conseils
pour toutes les femmes sylvie vartan
beauty boucle aux éditions un numéro un
alors bien sûr bonjour c'est bizarre
tant le sport en france vous avez lu ce
livre avec une grande attention ça avec
une grande attention et puis les photos
sont très très importante
alors j'ai fabriqué sur un air d'aérobic
un petit digest du livre de sylvie qui
comporte à la fois des conseils de
beauté de santé d'hygiène d'alimentation
de sport et qui raconte ses secrets
d'ailleurs elle doit sûrement avoir des
secrets parce que vous allez la voir
dans le livre on la voit 20 ans à 25 ans
à 30 ans est à 40 ans elle est chaque
fois de plus en plus belle alors qu'est
ce qu'elle fera à 90 voilà la mode et
alors c'est vrai musée des secrets
sylvie vartan vous aviez des secrets à
livrer comme ça vous savez j'ai commencé
à chanter à l'âge de 16 ans donc si vous
voulez pendant toutes ces années où j'ai
quand même dû faire attention à mon
image et surtout 1 1
un certain une certaine projection
puisque j'étais un personnage public
on apprend beaucoup de choses avec les
professionnels aussi et puis avec la
pratique surtout certains métiers en
fait le métier vous fait vous vous êtes
toujours obligé de vous surveillez de
faire extrêmement attention lancé ça
j'imagine qu'ils vous donnent l'habitude
non et puis aussi je crois que ça
correspond aussi à ma personnalité une
certaine manière je pense que c'était
une question de respect de soi même
aussi même si je n'étais pas chanteuse
ou un personnage public je crois que je
prêterai autant de soin à mon apparence
mais alors donc vous avez quand même de
secret là c'est un régime qui s'appelle
le 421 gpl a alors expliqué le sahara et
technique en fait c'est un set un régime
qui est déterminé par un apport de
glucides protides et de lipides bon ça
on sait que ce sont les sucres les les
protéines et puis aussi les graisses
en fait ça se résume en un régime plus
équilibrée plutôt que de faire un régime
draconien en sautant des repas ce qui
est très très mauvais ou en prenant
des médicaments ce qui est encore plus
parce que c'est vrai que dans nos vies
toujours pressé on veut des résultats
immédiats et spectaculaire au fond c'est
très mauvais mais non c'est vous qui
avez fait tout seul ce livre ou bien
vous avez collaboré j'imagine avec
d'abord des photographes avec des gens
qui l'on avait un secret oui il est gelé
et j'ai pris évidemment conseils sur des
sujets que je connaissais moins qui tout
du moins m'intéressait j'ai voulu un
livre clair et moderne dans sa mise en
page aussi et puis dans sa conception
évidemment j'ai travaillé en
collaboration avec martin sicard et
nadine corbasson géant verrier faire
comme jane fonda parce que jane fonda il
ya deux choses qui sont frappantes
d'abord elle a écrit un livre comme ça
aussi sur sur le corps sûr et surtout
sur être bien dans sa peau à 40 ans en
fait et c'est votre cas vous le dites en
tout cas oui bien sûr ça ça vient de la
beauté c'est bon c'est tout à fait
subjectif mais ça vient aussi de
l'intérieur mais aussi la beauté passe
par une bonne santé une bonne hygiène je
pense que c'est très important mais mon
livre traite la beauté en général pas
seulement uniquement sur la forme j'ai
voulu ce livre parce qu'il est un petit
peu différent des autres
les autres en général traite uniquement
de la forme de gymnastique et la
diététique d'une manière
très disons spécifique et un petit peu
spécial mon a l'impression que jane
fonda et vous vous découvrez le bonheur
à 40 en fait vous savez ça correspond
aussi à une certaine maturité et puis
jane fonda
elle est concerné par cela aussi on ne
peut pas faire un livre sur la beauté la
forme si ça ne vous intéresse pas par
exemple ou ne pas faire des studios de
danse si vous n'aimez pas danser on peut
pas faire un restaurant si vous n'aimez
pas manger vous n'y connaissez rien je
pense que le succès est aussi une
question de sincérité et de non mais
vous vous êtes vous et vous avez envie
un peu rika zaraï qui est un best seller
pour son histoire sur les médecines
douces et vous vous êtes dit je vais
faire mieux au produit tout dont je
n'envie personne d'abord je fais les
choses par coup de coeur j'analyse après
non je suis ravi du succès des autres je
pense que ça n'a rien à voir mais on me
sylvie vartan je rappelle le titre de ce
livre donc sylvie vartan but ebooks est
simple quand on vous voit on a envie de
regarder les conseils qui sont autant le
les bons conseils pour les autres sports
et les avantages et inconvénients
merci sylvain en voilà il est temps
maintenant de refaire